our our notions of dark matter and
mistaken and and do they have to be
radically reformed we still don't know
what dark matter is dark energy is I
pointed out it's a very different thing
it has a name dark in the name it is
true but it's a very different thing has
a very different effect it pushes the
universe apart while dark matter seems
such much more structure and during your
lera t and seems to associate yourself
with matter in some ways catherine you
measured the existence of dark matter
one might assume that she believes it
exists she does that with very new and
advanced ground-based telescopes
that allow her to map very large areas
of the sky and what you get out of this
filaments structure of dark matter that
you might have seen somewhere then we
have next to her as a being a awesome
Vader who is from the frankfurt
institute of advanced studies she the
theoretical physicists it's also
interested in dark matter and
alternative explanations for the
phenomena that we see when we think they
are made by dark matter and Eric
Valentin is the theoretical physicists
and he has recently built a theory that
does away with dark matter which is a
tricky business because the theory of
gravity has worked very well so far so
modifying it has to be done with great
care I start with Eric and then go this
way all right so I mean I'm not sure
whether you're all familiar of course
what dark energy and dark matter are
really about to mean dark energy is
related to observations of the fact that
the universe is expanding even
accelerated and we need in some
substance that spread over the universe
that explains this and it actually was
already part of Einstein's theory along
about a century ago that he could add
this possibility of adding a constant
that made the universe expand dark
matter is a totally different phenomenon
it has to do what happens in galaxies
and the fact there is more gravity there
that keeps galaxies together but also
the formation of galaxies in the
universe needs dark matter but that's an
hypothesis and it's true that most
theoretical physicists and
even cosmologists and as offices think
there is a dis particle out there that
explains this additional gravity because
then you can do it with the existing
theory why would you change the theory
at work so well as Einstein's theory if
well you can add this additional
component and explain these phenomena
for me the reason to doubt this is that
there's a theoretical reason why maybe
Einstein's theory doesn't work the way
it does and this has to do with our
insights that we have been gaining about
gravity over the last century after
Einstein we learned about quantum
mechanics we've learned more about how
the cosmos works I mean at the time of
Einstein people didn't understand even
the size of the cosmos was in fact there
were galaxies so we were dealing with an
old theory and there are reasons to
believe that it needed has to be changed
that comes from thinking about black
holes and even insights that come from
string theory which is a field I've been
working on tells you that simply
representing dark energy with this
constant of einstein's theory and
thinking about dark matter as a particle
is well may not be the right way
actually our reasons to believe that we
should modify gravity when we are
dealing with the very large distances I
mean like Einstein's gravity works very
well when gravity is very strong but in
galaxies when we are going further out
the gravity becomes very weak and this
is where the theory may be different and
what I'd like to explain in my way of
thinking about it is the connection
between these two objects that do
phenomena the dark energy and the dark
matter so dark energy is something that
I believe is really there in the sense
that there is a energy in our universe
that is required to explain its behavior
but the dark matter is not really a
particle it should be of an effect of
the dark the interactions between
ordinary matter and the dark energy so I
have sort of a mixed point of view on
dark energy in dark matter that I think
dark energy is really there but the dark
matter should not be a particle but it's
some way that gravity indeed works
differently in our galaxy in our unit
when we look at the interactions between
matter and and the dark energy thank you
very much maybe we go to Catherine you
measured the existence of dark matter so
do you think it is not there it's not
there it's tricky tricky I know I
measured something and we've called it
dark matter but III don't know what it
is I mean let me tell you what Who I am
I'm a professor of cosmology at the
University of Edinburgh and that means
it's it's my job to try and understand
the universe that's what a cosmologists
does now if we had a bunch of professors
of cosmology in this room we could
broadly split them up into two camps
now we'll call our first camp of
cosmologists we'll call them the the
smug cosmologists and they are rightly
so now these are the cosmologists who
have looked back to the universe as it
was right after the Big Bang and they
have made exquisite observations and use
that data to tell us exactly what makes
up our universe today less than 5% of
the universe is made up of the stuff
that we are made up of the stuff the
earth and the moon and the Sun and
everything you can see that accounts for
less than 5% of our universe then we
have 25% made up of dark matter the
strong gravitational force in our
universe that binds everything together
and the rest the other 70% something
that we've called dark energy that
appears to be causing the expansion of
our universe to get faster and faster
each and every day now this is a
beautiful theory it's a beautiful model
of our universe and it explains the
observations that our smug cosmologists
have made incredibly well there is no
better theory that we have to explain
these observations and so it's an
amazing testament to how far science has
come in terms of technology
instrumentation data analysis statistics
and theory that we've come to this point
of this beautiful match between
observations and theory so those are our
smart cosmologists and we
happen on the back because they've done
an amazing job now we have our other
group of cosmologists that we will call
the embarrassed cosmologists and I fit
certainly into this camp and the reason
why we're embarrassed is because if you
try to explain this model to anyone
who's not a professor of cosmology they
look at you nagar watts hey hang on hang
on hang on less than 5% of the universe
is made up of the stuff we are made up
of and hang on you've invented two
things that you've called doc and one of
them you've called dark matter because
it acts kind of like extra matter but
you don't know what it is you've never
seen it you've never touched it you just
think it's there you've invented it and
hang on a minute you're sourcing energy
out of nowhere to make an infinite
universe expand even faster this just
doesn't make sense and it is quite
embarrassing to to share share that
theory with someone so on the one hand
you know as cosmologists we're feeling
very pleased because we do have this
beautiful model of the universe now but
the flipside of that is it relies on
these two dark entities that to be very
honest with you we don't understand and
so to be frank we don't understand 95%
of the universe and you might be
thinking at this point Wow you
scientists totally failed that is an
epic fail you don't understand 95% of
the universe but I think everyone on
this panel will agree that you should be
looking at that in another way because
you should be seeing that as an amazing
opportunity when you don't understand
something is gargantuan there's 95% of
them universe it means you're missing a
key piece of the puzzle
maybe the framework that we're working
in isn't quite right and so yes you're
right I have mapped out the dark matter
in our universe I we have some beautiful
maps charting out where all of this
invisible stuff would be in a framework
where Einstein's theory of gravity is
right and we and it matches what our
theory predicts and another great
example of observations matching the
theory but we still haven't found that
thought of matter particle and until
that day comes I I remain the the
observer
in here and it's my job to test the
theories that people like Eric ins been
come up with and try and disprove them
so mean dark matter dark energy
he believes dark energy exists certainly
okay so I'm a theoretical physicist and
my task is to come up with explanations
for what the astrophysicist find
preferably some simple explanations
because if you have a lot of parameters
you can fit pretty much everything so
first I would like to object on this
idea that it that it is embarrassing
that we can't explain 95% of the
universe because this 95% is a totally
meaningless number the point is that
these 95% are really really simple at
least on cosmological scales we can
describe them with one parameter for
each there's the cosmological constant
and there's the average density of this
dark matter stuff and that's pretty much
it so I would agree that this is a nice
and simple theory the problem is that if
you look at galaxies and Eric already
said that our best observations about
dark matter and so on come apparently
from the galaxies then it's not quite as
simple you actually have to do some work
to get these galaxies to work out
properly the thing is that you can do it
with dark matter because this is stuff
that is distributed somewhere in the
universe and you can put it in the right
amounts wherever you need it so if I
give you any galaxy and you have to
explain what you see there you just put
the dark matter where it has to be in
the right amount and then you call this
an explanation so now from the
perspective of theoretical physicists
that's a little bit unappealing in
particular because if you look at the
structures of galaxies they have a lot
of regularities that are really really
hard to explain with this hypothesis of
dark matter one of which is for example
that the amount of dark matter in a
galaxy and not only the amount but also
the distribution seems to very closely
track the amount of vis
matter and you can make that work with
particle dark matter you can't calculate
it on a paper but you have to do fairly
complicated computer simulations and
after they've been twiddling with these
simulations for 20 years and added a lot
of parameters they've managed to produce
some galaxies that look like what we
actually observe now on the other hand
there are various theories that modify
gravity from which Eric Eric theory is
one and they manage to get these
regularities out basically in a two line
calculation and I find it very hard to
believe that there is not something to
it so now I want to answer specifically
the question that you had here are our
notions of dark matter and dark energy
radically mistaken so I've taken offense
with a question of course it's not our
notions that our mistake it's everyone
else no it's actually a mixture of dark
matter and modified gravity in the sense
that it is some kind of particle that
sometimes behaves in a way that looks
like it modifies gravity so it is a
particle which gives me as a particle
physicists hope that maybe I can still
build detectors that find it but let us
let us go back to Eric you have
basically removed the need for for dark
matter and and another said that in her
view of dark matter there's not a simple
element it has and distributed however
you want to make the theory fit you have
many parameters after all so is it so
them that we don't need any dark matter
and extend this question what about the
other mysterious darkness and there the
dark energy can we get rid of either get
rid of that or incorporate it into a
knife theory where emerges in a sensible
way so as I mentioned already in my
first opening remarks is that I think
there's a fundamental difference between
adding dark energy or dark matter dark
matter is assumed to be poor
very much like the particles we are made
of dark energies as other mysterious
stuff that we don't know what it is I
believe that we have to first of all
explain all of these things and not just
one without the other and and I for me
the dark energy is something that I
think means that we have a some
mysterious component of energy in our
universe so that our universe is not
really in its lowest energy state we
have sort of added from there and we
have to explain this and so I see our
current theories are clearly not enough
to describe what dark energy is that but
I think when we understand that we can
also explain those phenomena that we now
attribute to dark matter and then we
don't need it but that doesn't mean that
I have already deceived completely ready
there I mean we I made some calculations
that could explain what happens in
galaxies those regularities that Sabina
talked about those regularities come out
of this idea but there's another role
for dark matter which has to do with
this early universe explaining what
happens in well the observations of what
was called the Cosmic Microwave
Background or the way that structure
forms and so these cosmologists that are
using dark matter to explain all these
phenomena very precisely they indeed use
very specific ratios of these things to
explain this I have to do still the same
thing I mean this is some work for me to
be done but then I have to do it without
adding this dark matter and so this is a
challenge still I mean the theories are
not complete yet but this is where I
think indeed the fact that we have this
mystery out there is for a theorist an
ideal opportunity to solve these
problems and it doesn't always mean that
those solutions already the first one
that people thought about like adding
dark matter maybe a different way and
for me it's indeed trying to understand
gravity better and then explaining all
those phenomena but dark energy for me
would be an element actually that should
be added and maybe I should mention this
I mean I have many colleagues in string
theory that are working on a universe
that does not contain dark energy or
even if the opposite sign of what we
call the dark energy enemy a negative
cost motive constant that's a
mathematical universe that doesn't look
like ours but they can understand
gravity very well there so I have to
take those
people and motivate them to also work on
this universe that does have dark energy
in it in the positive contribution and I
think that is a very important component
of our universe we have to take that
seriously so will we be able to make a
mathematical universe that matches the
real one but means that it has a
positive dark energy and an expanding
universe with you or a model where you
take dark energy it's there that's how I
understand it and you have essentially
gravity itself emerge from something I
don't understand but we just didn't talk
to us first maybe I go back to Kathryn
he can explain how galaxies move in his
model it seems can he explain how you're
when you're measuring dark matter by
measuring how slight deviations of light
going all the way through an even
universe how light slightly deflected by
the mass by the gravitational pull of
dark matter which is not quite the same
as of thinking of of galaxies moving
around each other's or stars moving in
galaxies which is the most famous
evidence I'm talking about yeah does it
work so Eric and I actually have
published a paper together we were one
of the it was one of the first papers
that tested your theory and let's take a
little step back so what we how do we
actually see this invisible dark matter
so I said I've mapped out this dark
matter you're probably thinking well if
it's invisible how the hell is she
mapped it well what we do is we look at
very distant galaxies light travels
through the universe for about seven
billion years and as that light travels
through the universe it doesn't travel
in a straight line its path gets twisted
and pulled by the gravitational pull of
all of these invisible dark structures
around it and so what we do is we spend
a lot of time on remote mountaintops far
away from all of the light pollution in
cities and we
take very very deep images of the
universe collecting all this light from
these distant galaxies and then we
interrogate that light to tell us about
its journey it's seven billion year
journey from that galaxy to our
telescope what we can do is we can work
out how its lights been bent and
distorted by all of this invisible stuff
that's out there now I said that you
said you know does Dark Matter exists I
know that something's there I know that
there's something that's curving space
and time that's distorting these images
of the very distant universe that I map
out but I don't know what it is but I
know it's there and what we did when we
when we tested Eric's model was we said
okay what would it predict for the
gravitational pull around galaxies and
when we started working on it I was like
this is never gonna work
this is gonna be great we're gonna
disprove this theory in a week
unfortunately not Margo who is leading
this analysis she's a fantastic PhD
student in Leiden at the time came up
with these results and she compared our
best model of what dark matter should be
with with Eric's theory and found that
it fitted our data equally well so both
theories fitted our observations equally
well and but what was important this is
what Sabine was saying was that this new
theory requires we say no free parameter
so a parameter is it is something in
your theory that you can use to tweak
tweak and turn the knobs to boost the
theory or lower it and there's no free
parameter in this theory and that was
very motivating and supportive of this
theory but I think you know Eric does
and team and collaborators and indeed
you've written a paper extending this
analysis this theory as well and I think
that's where we need to be going because
yeah I would love the particle physics
experiments to actually catch a Dark
Matter particle or I'd love someone in
CERN to create a Dark Matter particle
because then that piece of the puzzle
would be done and you know maybe that's
just around the corner stones going up
going through an upgrade it's going to
be colliding particles together much
faster with much higher energies than
it's ever done before
maybe they'll be enough to create
a Dark Matter particle the simplest
theory that we think is out there and
we've got that bit solved but until that
happens I think we've got to investigate
new theories something you investigate
yourself new theories going taking some
of Eric's ideas I understand and your
own and as we mentioned earlier in
Europe your favorite model they're still
a particle in there yes at least you
could interpret it this way so I have
not written a paper with Eric but I read
a paper or I tried to read it and while
I was reading the paper I was reminded
of a passage from Stephen Weinberg spoke
dreams of a final theory where he
describes that there are two types of
theoretical physicists there are the
CEOs and the Mystics and the CEOs are
the ones who make an argument
straightforwardly go from A to B to C
and everything one follows after the
other and you can very easily follow
their argumentation and the Mystics they
assemble a cloud of facts which they lay
out and then a miracle happens and out
comes the result and I think that Eric's
is definitely of the second kind and I
had a hard time making sense of the
paper so I said I would try to put this
into a more digestible form and I found
interestingly two things one is that he
says he needs to start with dark energy
and then dark matter is a consequence
from this so I find that if you try to
write it down in a rigorous mathematical
way you actually get both together so
you do not you do not need to start with
assuming that dark energy is there but
they're both parts of the same story
Eric did you not write it down in the
rigorous mathematical way
and you need to fix there is a starting
point I mean I mentioned this that if
you want to really make things
mathematically rigorous we we haven't
found the model yet for our actual
universe at positive dark energy the
people that are working my fieldwork
have to work in this fictitious universe
with a negative cosmological to be
mathematically rigorous but mathematical
rigor or very medical medical precise
things can sometimes be Ethan tube
constraining so I laid out a number of
ideas and assumptions and from there on
I started reasoning
I think mathematically precise in the
sense that the steps are mathematically
precise but I have to make also some
hypotheses in there which I'm motivated
from a certain intuition so physics
cannot be started from no assumptions at
all and then just reasoning you have to
make some hypotheses and then continue
and then that's that's what I wrote down
is mathematically precise but it's based
on certain assumptions now one could be
forgiven for thinking okay twenty years
ago we could have had a very similar
debate quite the same we didn't have
Eric's theory for example twenty years
ago but nonetheless there was evidence
for dark matter cosmological evidence
evidence based on the fact on that how
light bends in under greater influence
and also already somewhat we didn't
really touch on that very much on dark
matter evidence and cosmic microwave
background and early structure of
formation of the universe which also
touches on to the dark energy side a
little bit so why haven't we moved on
libido
yes I'm happy to say something about it
but I feel like I should add something
here because I think that some of you
might be missing a piece of the story
because up to now you might have gotten
away with the impression that Eric's
model actually explains it all so why
are we even discussing this the point is
of course that it does not there are
some observations that at least it
presently cannot explain for example the
structure that we see in a cosmic
microwave background this is just
something where for which particle dark
matter works very very well but that at
least presently cannot be explained with
modified gravity and there are also some
problems with other observations so this
is why there is still a debate in the
community right so just one is ought to
be on the same table now the issue about
why we haven't made progress one of the
reasons why this hypothesis of proteger
Dark Matter became so widely adapted was
that thirty years ago or so theoretical
physicists had a lot of other reasons to
believe in the existence of additional
particles that conveniently enough also
could make up dark matter for example
there there is an extension of our
current theories that is called
supersymmetry in which you get a lot of
additional particles some of which just
have the right properties to make up
dark matter and this certainly land a
lot of credibility to this hypothesis
now people have looked for these
particles since the mid 80s with
increasingly higher precision you know a
bill are larger detectors and better
apparatuses and they haven't found any
and now the most recent round of
experiment just concluded and I think
there's now you know some sense in the
community where people are asking
yourself how far do we really want to
push this like do we want to continue
building larger and larger detectors
forever trying to hope to find this
particle which may not even be there
now the particle physicists we would
probably not say we have concluded quite
yet I mean the next generation of Dark
Matter experiments should increase
sensitivity by a factor of 100 so
there's my toe quite a distance to go
but Katherine has a fellow
experimentalists yes do you think we
have made no progress I saw why it's
always an interesting interplay in
science between theory experimentation
and instrumentation and it's what drives
what so normally the way it works is
kind of a looper a theorist will come up
with a really awesome theory and an
observer on experimentalists will design
an experiment to go out and test that
theory and that may take require
innovation new technology that will
eventually feedback into a wider wider
realm but they'll they'll test the
theory and they'll find something new
which will stimulate another theory
which will stimulate another experiment
more instrumentation and and so on and
so forth and I think you know you say we
haven't moved on but actually this is a
really short amount of time if you want
that loop to work so what we're very
excited about at the moment is next year
we are going to be opening a brand new
telescope in Chile again on top of a
beautiful mountain top high above the
clouds and very very dry region it's
called the large survey synoptic
telescope and we're going to be imaging
the entire night sky every three nights
we're gonna be building it for 10 years
so absolutely massive telescopes one of
the largest telescopes that's going to
be working on the ground and we're going
to be building up the deepest image of
the universe yet which allows us to
confront a whole range of different
theories and in doing so it will
stimulate theorists to come up with even
more theories I mean it was only very
recently that it was when I was at
universities in 1998 was when the first
evidence came about for dark energy
now that's very recently and it's only
now well next year that will have the
instrumentation and ready to really
robustly test and these different
theories being a yachtie
in
your blog and your publications hint
that you think maybe the way we do
science scientific or academic process
might be holding us back in finding new
and unconventional theories can you
comment on that yes I will just latch on
to something that you just said that if
you get new results quite possibly null
results then this will stimulate
theories to come up with new theories
which is undoubtedly true because the
theories that they now have they can
always be adapted to accommodate a null
result and actually we have a huge
amount of theories for particle Dark
Matter already that can eternally be
adapted and that's very convenient if
you are a theorist because these are
basically theories that cannot be ruled
out now you were talking about this
virtuous cycle in which experiment go
out and they find some evidence and that
guides the development of new theories
but the problem is that null results are
very bad guides you know they tell you
very very little about the new theory
that you hope to develop and that risks
that we end up in a vicious cycle in
which the null results do not lead to
better theory so we get stuck with the
theories that were not good to begin
with we stimulate further of the more
experiments will lead further null
results and so on and so on
and personally I think we've been stuck
in a cycle for some while already and
one of the reason is that theorists i
think a lot are actually quite
comfortable with theories that cannot be
ruled out and now the great thing i want
to emphasize this again is that eric's
model at least in the way that's in the
paper doesn't have any free parameters
so it is a principle very easy to rule
out and that's quite a daring thing to
do yes please yes
beautiful difference between astronomy
and particle physics though when you
design the experiment for particle
physics it's to answer one question how
much money do we spend on certain
fabulous CERN is fabulous I love it it
discovered the Higgs boson fantastic
haven't found anything else yet they so
this wonderful telescope that I'm
talking about not only are we going to
be able to test theories about dark
matter and dark energy we're also going
to be mapping out all of the killer
asteroids that might one day obliterate
look after you reassuring I would argue
that we found things that sound actually
interesting ones but not yet a new
particle new composite particles but
they're not new fundamental ones yet and
certainly nothing that really
contradicts the standard model and
allows us to distinguish a standard
model from possible new physics models
with new particles in them some of them
could or could not be dark matter does
your model allow us to make such a test
can I go somewhere I about Katherine or
to CERN and say your model contains an
element allows me distinguish it from
the standard mainstream theory that dark
matter has a particle well there's
certainly the idea is that when he
developed a theory and you understand
better that you don't have all the three
parameters that allow you to explain
every observation so eventually one
other theory which has the particular
predictions for well things that you can
observe and I think those observations
will not be here on earth they're mostly
the kind of things that Katherine is
doing where you look at how dark matter
is distributed around the universe and
how it is behaving at least effectively
I mean this extra gravity that we see
how that's behaving you want to make
predictions for that and then you can
test these these ideas and so I feel the
reason why we didn't make a lot of
progress is that those observations were
not precise enough and we had these
crude models that could be adjusted by
so many parameters that they seem to be
be consistent with everything having
more precise observations and more
situations where we see dark matter
really directly what is doing then a
theory becomes also about testable and
you can exclude a theory if it's not a
youie that has all these adjustable
parameters you won't have a theory that
has a logical framework without being
just well too flexible yes but to to
push it a little bit further what we
really like as experimental is our
theories that I make predictions so
before the data from the NS STR there
that's right then make predictions that
then can be tested after the data arrive
have you got any of those no I bet but I
think that that this may be a very
beautiful time where theory and
experiment are working together I think
in understanding nature it's not like
the theorists have to be locked up in
one room and the experimental is in the
other one where the theories come out
and now they say we have something and
then the experimentalists say let's look
at this and then test it no there can be
exchanged and it doesn't mean that the
theories are developed to explain
exactly only the data but they can give
hints of what direction to go into so I
think the reason why we didn't make a
lot of progress may also because we had
not enough data to even guide us in the
right direction the complicated the
problems that we are having may be so
complicated is by sitting in a room you
may not just find the solutions you have
to also be able to see what your look
trying to explain this is a notion that
warms and experimentalists heart very
much because I also believe that data is
of course the the crucial element to
make progress so the last theme your
let's look again at your theory of an
example it's a very radically new theory
in many ways I mean as I mentioned at
touching gravity something many people
have tried and usually burned their
fingers because it is a very successful
theory already will the development of
such a radically new theory also give us
insights beyond dark matter will be will
change our view of the universe maybe
also in a way that one day I can find
new particles at CERN which would either
I understand that that's one of your
motivation but I think the the thing
issue was already raged Dark Matters
also needed to explain what's happening
in the early universe we want to
understand where all the structure comes
from and if we start understanding
gravity in a different way we may have a
different explanation of those same
phenomena and even have a different
story to tell about how many of these
things are rose I mean I'm not very
happy with the current way and we have
done this if we think about how we
extrapolated the current theory I mean
using Einstein's equations all the way
back they've made many assumptions and I
think that story may change but I think
it's it's a general fact that certain
theories eventually we were replaced by
the next one where we can explain more
phenomena and sometimes it's not even
easy to predict which phenomena can be
explained in advance I mean you have to
first go through the steps of developing
with the full theory and actually I'm
not doing this by myself in that sense
and maybe I would even put it well make
clear that I'm not only bending a new
theory or many theories thinking now
about changing the way that we think
about gravity in trying to define derive
it think about it as an emergent force
where we start from a different language
microscopically what my colleagues are
not seeing yet is the connection with
the phenomena associated with dark
matter but the fact that we have to
think about gravity in a different way
it's being done by many other theorists
at the same time so I think it's just a
matter of time before that theory is
developed and hopefully not by myself
only but by a group of theorists working
on this problem science is a
collaborative process that's why and not
not one by a single hero's rule I'd very
much like to hear that and it was
collaborative amongst theorists most
extra mentalists and clearly between
theory and experiment I mean it what do
we need to do to get a better theory of
everything
let's let's not help still care for
small things everything the universe our
universe my universe everybody's well I
do think that dark matter is a good
place to start with because in this case
at least we know there is something
there I mean we do have some
observations which cannot be said about
other problems that people have tried to
solve in the foundations of physics
where they worry that their equations
are not beautiful enough you know like
this search for unified force that
unifies the interactions that we have
and that may exist or it may not exist
so I think that dark matter is a good
place to start with but you were asking
about what what else can we learn from
it so there's an interesting thing about
Eric's approach which is that it tries
to make contact contact to a possibly
underlying structure of space-time so
the way that we currently deal with
space-time in our theories is that its
primary its fundamental it's just there
but there are some approaches that try
to give quantum properties also to
space-time which are generally collected
on the determine gravity of which a
string theory is one example that posit
that maybe there's something more to it
and one manifestation of such an
underlying theory could be something
that looks like dark matter so indeed
finding a dark matter finding out that
it is maybe best described by a theory
of modified gravity could also tell us
something about this underlying
structure of space-time which would
really be very very exciting and for me
it's also one of the motivations to work
on that thank you yes really what do we
need to do what do we need steam big
telescopes big basically up in space
yeah my ultimate dream if if some really
rich person is out there I really really
really like a liquid mirror telescope on
the Dark Side of the Moon please I think
that would be really awesome good like
carve out one of those craters have on
the dark side the room the bigger the
telescope you get the more information
more light you collect the further back
in the universe that you can see and
with more data more information we can
really test all these theories and
really find out the answers I always
think of sort of our job as astronomers
and looking back in the past if we
wanted our civilizations wanted to
explore the earth and I think what we
need to do now is explore the universe
and to do that really big telescope so
the way you want to go big got a
wonderful I have my part of it
I want big detectors not I would be on
the moon but down there
underground it was disturbed by all
these cosmic radiations all these things
to see the dark matter particles that
might or might not be there and
anecdotally rich person the the next big
thing of this kind of detector will be
built in the Stanford underground
Research Laboratory and Sanford would
need a very rich man who made his money
with credit cards so I don't know how
many families he ruined in the presence
of that but then but this love is
actually partly funded by by somebody
like my family I think my own lab and
safety I think the earth of moving
towards what's slowly toward the end of
this the audience should start thinking
about their questions while I'm making
my microphone somewhere go where
okay um and what we need to make
progress is more data elaboration more
theories more theories well maybe maybe
I should add something there I mean many
of my colleagues are indeed thinking
about a universe that's not like our own
and they are more motivated by the
mathematical consistency or the beauty
of their theory and I think we should
also motivate em to get out of their
room and contact and talk to these
nomads for us to do with reality reality
and then if a larger community works on
this I think this is the way to make
progress I think that's a very important
element otherwise it will not happen
indeed there has been a little bit and I
think that's one of your concerns have
been a motion towards theories that are
little disconnected from reality which
are very beautiful and very nice but
mainly mathematical and not so much Rico
well I agree with that point of view so
something to agree on many things to
agree on I mostly agreed broadly it's
time to wrap up now so thank you very
much to the audience and thanks to all
our panel members for a very interesting
debate and for answering all these
questions thank you very much
[Applause]